I'm Martin Jackson I'm a charge nurse
have worked in by the hospital for the
last 20 years in the last seven eight
years repairs which listed still with
two or three years where we had zero pay
rises it's probably fair to say that
across the country austerity fatigue has
well and truly satin I need to make
cutbacks need to juggle finances and
juggle lawns and juggle everything
really
my partner's wanted be getting money for
last two or three years ago that's just
an impossible so a dream at many and
that in a sense is what austerity boils
down to a million difficult decisions
some eroding the pay for workers like
Martin some cutting back on investments
at this hospital some trimming spending
on local authority workers like street
cleaners or binman
down the road Sheffield has felt the
effects more than most and the council
says there's simply nothing left to cut
I don't think there are any efficiencies
that we could really suggest at this
stage after taking 390 million out of
our budget and that exists I think this
is coming down to frontline services
this is Sheffield Central Library an
icon a municipal Britain
now some rooms are closed some of the
week because so many staff have had to
be cut the ceilings are cracked there
are leaks damp broken windows
it'll cost tens of millions to renovate
so the plan is to sell this 1930s Art
Deco masterpiece to chinese developers
to be turned into a hotel which raises
another issue now it's all very well to
say let's end austerity but what does
that actually mean does it mean giving
30 million pounds to get this library
revamped does it mean rehiring all of
those librarians that we've got rid of
what about nurses salaries police the
fire service what about all the people
facing a freeze in their benefits what
about all that infrastructure that we
were supposed to have done rail roads
energy and so on the point is that in
many ways ending austerity raises more
questions than it answers but public
opinion is shifting the new sky data
survey found that 56% of people would
support an increase in state spending
even if they had to pay more in tax a
point nick clegg agrees with but the
Deputy Prime Minister who impose
austerity said brexit would make it even
harder to reverse it it's pretty rich
for brexit ears to shed crocodile tears
about the pressure on public sector pay
when it was there it was their
determination to pull us out of the
European Union that's leading to the new
pressure on their on their take-home pay
and it's unbelievable that the goal that
could spur Michael Gove and Boris
Johnson a million difficult decisions
still trickling their way through the
economic system millions of lives still
affected still the cuts continue at
Conway Sky News